there's another topic that's starting to
percolate now and obviously if it bleeds
it leads and when you have a quote and
and this is the quote that's going to be
used
as clickbait and it's not
it's not you know it's not clickbait of
the type where when you click on it the
quote is different than what you were
led to believe it's going to be but this
is a headline and this is something that
people are going to be talking about
kirk cousins of vikings quarterback in a
podcast with kyle brandt a month ago and
that's the look i don't like this put
the interview in the can
and and and and
put it out for everyone a month later
because the world changes too fast a
month is too long to have something in
the can because it's entirely possible
kirk cousins views have changed over the
course of the last month but as of a
month ago before it was time to go to
training camp he was talking about his
concerns as it relates to covet 19
and
he was asked the specific question on a
scale of one to ten
if one is the person who says masks are
stupid and you're all a bunch of
lemmings and ten is i'm not leaving my
master bathroom for the next 10 years
where do you land
cousin said i'm not going to call
anybody stupid for the trouble it would
get me in but i'm about a .00001
meaning he's even farther beyond the
masks or stupid crowd as it relates to
not worrying about covet 19 and he was
asked to explain why and here's what he
said now apparently he chuckled a little
bit and we need to hear it and maybe
there's video at some point we can get
an idea but these are the words
i want to respect what other people's
concerns are for me personally just
taking no one else can get the virus
what is your concern if you get it i
would say i'm going to go about my daily
life if i get it i'm going to ride it
out i'm going to let nature do its
course survival of the fittest kind of
approach and just say if it knocks me
out it knocks me out i'm gonna be okay
you know even if i die if i die i die
i kind of have peace about that the
headline is gonna be if i die i die
and uh you know this is where
self-awareness needs to come into it and
you need to self-edit yourself when
you're answering questions like this
chris but this is going to end up being
a big deal today and he's going to end
up having to deal with it and and the
vikings need to make him available to
the media sooner rather than later so he
can explain it so you can provide more
context so he can say i've changed my
mind but that kind of cavalier attitude
is not good it's not good it's not the
message we want sent to people who need
to be careful you you and and i
understand and look it's that attitude
hey i can get hit by a truck at any time
yeah but you could also avoid getting
hit by a truck by not walking out into
the street right so uh
it's just look i we're all processing
this kind of on the fly but i have a
feeling this again ended up being a big
deal today well i mean listen we know
masks work i mean that's that's not even
debatable it's that's we know that i
mean that's why we are in the position
we are in in our country because we
didn't ever have a
a plan you know that came together and
mask being a part of it like other
countries where they have no covert you
know 19 outbreaks for a period of time
now they've been on that so yeah it's
insensitive that way but i don't think
he's trying to be insensitive at least
the way it reads to me you know i think
he's
i think he doesn't like the mask and
he's saying basically
he doesn't fear the virus i do think
when he's trying to say just talking no
one else can get the virus what is your
concern like i do think he respects
humanity i don't think this is a guy
that's going to go out and like cough on
people and be like oh it's covid deal
with it it's not a big deal he's gonna
do that but i think like we've heard
from most football players and like
we've always talked about and i think
brady showed us the same thing you know
a lot of them are hey they respect the
virus but i don't think there's fear of
the virus and they're going to go on
with life and they believe they're young
and healthy and you know they're not
going to be affected by it right so
but this is no different than tom
brady's the only thing we have to fear
is fear itself it's just elaborate it's
more deeply more elaborate
it's the quiet part being spoken out
loud which is another phenomenon of
modern society so it doesn't really
surprise me but the point is he occupies
a position of influence over others
right
and if you are saying things like that
other people
may think yeah you know what if i die i
die and maybe they're going to be a
little more cavalier and again it's not
about you
it's about ensuring that you don't
contribute the spread of the virus to
others and specifically to the people
who aren't part of the fittest who would
survive
you know again he probably used that
phrase flippantly
but
there's a way to utter the
concept of survival of the fittest by
saying hey i think i'll make it and the
hell with you if you don't survival of
the fittest i don't think he meant it in
that kind of in your face you know we're
going to thin the herd here right and
the strongest fastest best are going to
survive but you got to be careful when
you utter that phrase in this context
because it could be interpreted as very
insensitive to the weaker members of
society that we are trying to protect
yeah that's that's what it's all about
again
you know i i don't think this is a bad
guy in any stretch of the imagination i
think this is a guy that cares about
people you and i have been around him
this is no jerk of a person but yeah i
think he could have done a little bit
better job answering that question and
yeah he's going to have some explaining
to do today certainly you know i i think
that he's gonna have to add a little
more context to the situation in general
uh but i i think this is a pretty common
thought throughout football right now
and again not to say that these guys
these guys are i think a lot of them
respect it and they don't want you know
their mom and dads or their grandparents
to get sick or anything like that but i
think if they're just saying if that
wasn't around you know they would they
wouldn't be in fear of this virus at all
and i just think that's what he was
trying to convey even though i don't
know if he conveyed it in the uh the
best manner there and and i agree with
you completely this gets back to what
you were saying from the early days of
the pandemic football players don't care
football players believe that it won't
get them and if they get it they will
beat it that so
he
ideally he would have stopped short of
saying if i die i die i think the truth
is that the football players think i'm
not going to die right it's not gonna
get me right i'm fine with it bring it
on inject it into my veins and i'll kick
its ass right remember what gardner
minshew said the virus saw me and took
off running yeah that's the attitude i
mean that was funny and that was clearly
a joke but that's the attitude football
players have yeah so yeah if i die i die
is more along the lines of i ain't gonna
die
no right i'm not worried about it's not
even a thought it's not and you know i
don't mean to sound insensitive or
anything like that but that's just the
way these guys are wired it's the way i
was wired i'm still wired to that to a
degree you know yes it's just go forward
i'm healthy i'm strong nothing's going
to hurt me until it hurts you and you
lose a spleen you go oh crap maybe i'm
not indestructible but that's still just
the wiring of most nfl football players
yeah i uh i agree with you completely
and again i i
look i i've been among the first to
criticize kirk cousins for football
reasons i just think that that
i mean it was stupid for him to use the
language that he used and it was dumb
and he's gonna have to deal with it now
but i i understand the deeper point he
just should have either articulated it
better or kept it to himself because
there are too many impressionable people
out there who are looking for
that and that's the thing it's not just
the people who are going to hear that
and say oh yeah i agree with kirk
cousins people are looking for anything
to back up their view that masks are
dumb and and you're a sheep for wearing
a mask and if kirk cousin says it's no
big deal not that kirk cousins is you
know going to be on i like if it's
patrick mahomes it'd be different i
don't know how much influence kirk
cousins frankly has at this point but
it's just not it's not good because
there will be people who seize on those
words as justifying their own behavior
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports